as a surgery you have to inject fat into
the penis to make it thicker that sounds
way cooler dude have you actually seen
how those look no I pull one up and then
show your face man it really does look
pretty crazy all right here let me go
Incognito what do I even [__] put in
this fat injected dick that injected and
then just write Anthony
by Anthony Lee oh my God it's not good
let me see let me see it doesn't look so
clean so clean so Colleen we're such
[__] children show College hey
Colleen are you coming yet are you
coming
she's not but I am these pics are great
dude
holy [__] oh so why do you even get the
procedure if clearly I think it's up
here more a little bit but what if it
works what if it works you guys ever
heard about dudes uh it's not working
you guys ever heard about guys putting
marbles in their dick